we are having a great lineup of four
speakers for you
michael walters jody samuels
marina villatoro alla peters
and special guest bob piacino
this session will be recorded and sent
to your email
please take a look at your go to webinar
control panel
into the questions area you'll be able
to ask any questions you want
during the speaker's i would like to
begin and bring to the show
our first guest michael walters
good morning michael good morning anna
thanks for having me here let me just uh
get my screen up here okay hopefully you
can see my
screen and you can hear me okay
the screen looks good to me you have 45
minutes
okay great thanks anna again yo thanks
for having me here good morning
everybody thanks for uh taking the time
out today it's uh
you know it's summertime here in the u.s
and you know we just had the fourth of
july holiday so it's kind of a shortened
week you know
and it's it's um
even though it's short and weak you know
there's still a lot of i don't say
fireworks going on in the market but
you know the markets keep moving and you
know as traders we want to
always be looking for good trading
opportunities and what are we talking
about today is
how to find winning trades in the order
flow now
what you're going to learn today is
three things
why order flow you know what makes order
flow so important to us
as as traders and how order flow will
help your trading
how to find winning trades in the order
flow and i'm going to do it you know
fairly quick you know
we got 45 minutes today but you know to
be honest really learning how to trade
with order flow is something that
is once you understand it you know is is
very easy to pick up and if you stick
around until the end i'll give you a
copy of my book called trading
order flow you know a few years ago
probably about 2014 2015 i started
writing this book
on trading or flows my way to give back
to the trading community
and you know as a beginning trader back
in the early
um 1990s you know i i had a lot of
traders
help me along the way and you know times
have changed you know this
for those of you that are new to one of
my presentations my name is michael
baltos i'll just give you a quick
background on myself you know i started
on the cme floor as a runner with dean
witter
reynolds that was back in the early 90s
and eventually i left the trading floor
when electronic trading started picking
up
and i spent about three years on the
upstairs trading desk trading globex
project a which is the board of trade
and nymex comex electronic as well as
all the foreign exchanges
that were open overnight you know
trading life trading uh cymax trading
it was dtb back then which was your x
and it really exposed me to a lot of
different
markets you know and it was great
because you know there are so many
markets beyond
just what trades in the united states
and after that i joined edf man
in chicago on the global macro trading
desk i spent two years there edf man is
a big english trading
company after edf man i joined commerce
bank in chicago i was a licensed urex
trader
you know i was one of about a handful of
people that were licensed to trade
um buns bobble shots dax
euro stocks on eurex
and after commerce bank right i joined
cargill the big commodity trading firm
you know it's a privately held company
and it's for you know the first or the
second largest
privately held company in the united
states they account for about 30
of us grain exports about 25 of the meat
exports but they literally trade
everything
under the sun everything that's tradable
they trade
and after cargill they sent me out to
singapore actually cargill did they set
up a trading desk then i
after um the part of
cargill that i was working for got sold
i took some
about six months off and then i joined
jp morgan as vice president of futures
training i spent eight years there
now this was a trading position this is
not sitting in the back office looking
at statements or
you know looking at numbers that other
traders are doing this is sitting on the
trading desk banging away on the
computer's
trading and in 2013 i left jp morgan
when after my first daughter was born
because you know i want to spend more
time with my family as opposed to just
basically coming in the office at six in
the morning and staying there
until five in the evening you know i i
wanted a life and
i know that trading gives you that
opportunity if you are
good at trading if you are successful at
trading why not just
do it on your own terms right so i
started a couple years later
i started writing my book in 2014 and in
but six years ago i started the order
flows.com
website and it's centered around the
order flows trader software now the
reason i just talk about the software
is because the charts that you see in
this presentation are
generated from my order flows trading
software it runs on ninjatrader eight
and it's a volume footprint chart with a
bunch of pre-programmed
uh order flow indicators in there to
help you understand
what you're seeing in the order flow now
before i dump it jump into the
details you know just brief disclaimer
do understand that
risk that trading involves risk okay
risk capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security a lifestyle
and you should only trade with money
that you can afford to lose
um you know sometimes people lose sight
of that you know
they think that it's a race against time
like oh my gosh you know i lost my job
i'm on benefits for the next three
months
i got to learn how to trade so i don't
have to go back to work well don't
give yourself that unnecessary pressure
right no matter whether you're trading
or in doing any endeavor
you know extra pressure
makes people in general perform worse
than
better now why order flow
okay well order flow allows you to see
things other traders don't see because
they're just following
price up or down right you look at a
normal bar chart
and you're just seeing oil price went up
price went down
and you're not really understanding why
price is going up or down and when you
just follow price up or down you don't
see the intensity or the force behind a
move
and why is that important is because
well if you don't understand
you know is the move getting weaker
as you know say the market is going up
but it's going up you know on weaker
strength
then what's going to happen right it's
not going to go up much further it's
going to reverse and
sell off and conversely if the market is
selling off all day long selling off
selling off selling off
but it gets to that point where you know
the selling
really gets weakened and you know sort
of everybody's done selling well what do
you think the market is going to do well
it's going to stop and
and turn around and go back up and if
you're looking at just
you know your normal chart this is crude
oil this morning
you're going to miss a lot of
this information right you can see how
the market is is selling off
selling off selling off then stops and
reverses you know quite
dramatically okay and if you're just
looking at a normal bar chart you're not
going to know
what's going on down here that's causing
also in this market to
snap back up to where we were before the
sell-off
but if you're looking at order flow
right you can see
what's happening in the different
aspects of order flow which i'll explain
in a moment you know you can see the
deltas getting weaker
as you're selling off then all of a
sudden you hit the bottom and delta gets
really strong
you're seeing buying imbalances appear
when earlier there was mostly selling
imbalances and you're seeing
volume migrate higher in terms of the
point of control
right and you know the way i i like to
describe it
is you know i mean you know
sort of this trump vernacular you know
it's like playing 3d chess right
if you're just playing 2d chess you're
just seeing what's happening
right in front of you a 3d chest you got
to look what's happening above and below
you
and how one move is going to affect
everything else now
remember markets trade in a two-way
auction right traders are working bids
and other traders are working offers
but trades aren't going to happen unless
someone becomes
aggressive and crosses the bid offer
spread
right remember so like for example the
market could be five bid
at i'm sorry six bid at seven right it's
six bid on 50 contracts
maybe there's 80 offered at seven well
no no trade is going to happen because
it's just six bid at seven for a trade
to happen either
someone that's offered at seven has to
go down and hit the sixes
or someone that's bidding six
has to become aggressive become an
aggressive buyer
and all of a sudden lift his bid up from
six to seven right that's how trades
happen
so you know just because you see bids
and offers no trade is happening
until someone crosses that bid offer
level now
how is the force or intensity of trade
measured right that's that's what i said
you know is the big difference between
looking at a normal bar and candlestick
chart
as opposed to a footprint chart well
you can measure it in different ways
right there's three main parts of order
flow that are used to measure it there's
delta
it's point of control and there's
imbalances okay
now delta is a difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar
now remember i just said what an
aggressive buyer aggressive seller is
it's someone who crosses the bid
offer line okay and if delta
is positive buyers are in control right
if you have a positive delta
it's telling you that there was say
delta is one
okay it's telling you there was one
aggressive buyer
overall in that bar if the delta is 255
there's in that bar is telling you
there's 255 more aggressive buyers
than sellers in that bar now if delta is
negative
it's telling you sellers are in control
right so if it's negative 300 when the
bar closes
it tells you in this bar there was 300
more
aggressive sellers than aggressive
buyers in the bar
now delta is important to watch because
you can clearly see who's in control of
the bar
and of the market so how does it look on
a chart well
most footprint charts and mine included
put the delta on the bottom right some
people like to put it above or below the
bar
i like to have it on the bottom um it's
just you know it's it's a nice place to
have it so i know
what's happening where to look for it at
all times
and you can see there's red color
boxes and there's green right red tells
you it's negative green tells you it's
it's positive then you can see the
numbers right so
for example this arrow is pointing down
at this bar
it's got a delta of minus 50. so it's
telling me there's
50 more aggressive sellers in that bar
than aggressive buyers
now after this low is made we have a
green bar that's got
positive delta of 115 okay
so that's telling me there was 115 more
aggressive buyers than aggressive
sellers in that bar
so they're outnumbering the aggressive
buyers are outnumbering
the aggressive sellers if it's positive
delta
and if it's negative delta aggressive
sellers outnumber
the aggressive buyers so as you can see
as the market's moving down
generally you have negative delta okay
as the market starts moving
up you're seeing positive delta okay
so that's a delta now point of control
or poc is the short
version of it is um it's the price level
in the bar with the most volume traded
in that bar and most traders think that
all traded prices
are equal right and if you're looking on
a bar chart you don't know the volume
that's traded at a price level you just
know that price traded there
but volume matters right
not all traded prices are equal okay and
if you've ever run a business
you know whether it's you know a store
or selling something on ebay
you know if you you understand how
important volume is
right because you could raise your
prices
up and up and up people will still buy
but it's going to get to a point where
you raise your price is too high
it shuts off buying right because it's
just too high people aren't interested
in buying it from you anymore
and you know just as if you lower prices
all right people you know will
think oh this is a good deal it's a good
deal and you keep lowering prices people
are going to stop
buying from you because they think well
you know price hasn't hit slow yet
they'll just sit back and wait till it
hits it's low so
what volume that trades at price is is
important because again you know if
price gets too high
people become disinterested right and if
price gets too low
people become interested
at a certain point then they start
coming in and then you see volume pick
up again
so something that traders don't realize
is that it's not so much how much volume
trades
but it's also where volume trades that's
important okay
and point of control again is the price
level in the bar where the most volume
trades
okay so imagine if if a price trades
heavy volume well it's being accepted
right but what if
prices trade light volume well it's
probably
that's probably a sign that that price
is being rejected
and there's so many different ways you
can use volume
you know one of the the easiest ways to
use volume in a bar
the simple point of control the price
level in the bar with the most volume
is by watching well is volume migrating
higher
or migrating lower right and it's not
like you really got to sit there and
scratch your head and try and figure it
out
it's simple you just look at the chart
as this market is moving down what do
you see
is point of control point of control
point of control point of control point
of control point of control
lower lower lower right so lower one
two three four five six seven eight
then what happens it turns right you got
a higher point of control
higher point control higher point
control higher point of control higher
point of control
so as volume is migrating lower
price is going down right
as price goes up volume is also
migrating up
until it turns right until it starts
migrating back down again
right that's that's how you can watch
volume
to see market direction okay
now the third part of order flow
101 if you want to call it that is
imbalances right and imbalances occur
when the market is out of equilibrium
now people
often have this this macro view of the
market you know the market was out of
balance today
but imbalances in the order flow is um
you know
imbalances in the particular bar okay
now generally right two-sided trade is
fairly even
all right you see most volumes go
through you know maybe it's
you know when you're looking at the bid
offer it's six bit at seven you know
50 trade on the bid 100 trade on the
offer
it's when you start seeing
percentages you know or much more
aggressive buying or much more
aggressive selling that's when an
imbalance
comes in and you could determine what
level you want to use
for an imbalance
so most traders use at least four to one
okay now you don't have to use four to
one that's four hundred percent and you
know some use three hundred
actually some use five hundred some use
a thousand but
basically when you say four to one
right to cause and imbalance what that
would mean is say the market is six bit
at seven
if six six is traded
just 50 times but seven's traded
400 times you know that's obviously
greater than four to one you'd say you
have a buying imbalance and how does it
look on a chart
this is how it looks on a chart i just
drove drew arrows at a few of them
right so remember it's a percentage
right it's not
in volume terms so you can see there's
some imbalances one against twelve
eight against forty those are buying the
balance is two against seventeen
zero against forty one right you can see
three against twelve
seven against forty one um zero against
10 against 54. again you could adjust
what imbalance you want to look at like
say you want to look at five to one
so you want to look at ten to one you
can do that
okay now some people also like to filter
out by size you know just take
imbalances you know four to one with
volume over 50.
personally i just prefer just look at
the the imbalances i got eyes i can see
i don't need to have that filtered out i
just want to know where the imbalances
are really quick
i can see the volume myself now why is
that important
because generally as markets are selling
off you're seeing
mostly selling of balances okay right as
you can see here
this bar three selling it balances this
bar three sauna balances this one's got
five cell imbalances then as you know
you hit the low here you got three sauna
balances
but then the market starts coming back
with what buying imbalances
buying imbalances three here two here to
here
so you all of a sudden what was
aggressive selling on the way down now
you're starting to see
aggressive buying as the market goes
back up right
so once you understand delta
point of control and imbalances then you
can start to use that information to
understand
what is actually happening in the market
rather than just following
price you know up or down right because
now you could understand
okay you know here you know people like
to follow price action you know you come
down you hit a low you got a green
candle
okay well what do you got well you still
got negative delta so you got still
overall
selling in this bar well you do have a
couple buying imbalances
okay that's bullish point of control is
still lower
than the previous points of control so
you know volume is still migrating down
and what happens you still go lower
until you get to this new low
where all of a sudden now you've got
positive delta
okay whereas earlier you didn't have
positive delta now you got
a couple binding balances like you did
earlier but point of control is also
higher
than the previous bar right and you also
take out the high of the previous bar
so you know if you're following order
flow you know that this
is just you know maybe a little bit of
people covering their shorts
it's not a serious rally just yet but
when you get over here
you can see the aggressive buying
in terms of delta in terms of imbalances
and you see volume starting to migrate
higher
okay so that's that's a much better bar
to be getting long off of than
than this one here earlier
so how will order overflow help your
trading is
it's going to keep you on the right side
of the market right more importantly
alert you to when market conditions are
changing
right and and that's important it's
because you know as a trader you want to
know
are market conditions changing you know
have we gone from
a bearish scenario to a bullish scenario
or vice versa from bullish
or from bearish to bullish so you know
as a general rule if you're along and
you see bar after bar of positive delta
coming in you're probably pretty safe
and staying long
right if you're long and you see lots of
buying and balance is happening you're
probably pretty safe staying long
okay now if you're along and you see poc
coming in higher and higher you're
probably
safe staying in long and the opposite
would be true if you're short if you're
short
have a short position and you see bar
after bar of negative delta
it's pretty safe to stay short right if
you're short and you see lots of selling
and balances
appearing you're probably pretty safe
and staying short
and if you're along and you see point of
control coming in
i'll tell you if you're short and you
see point of control coming in lower and
lower
every bar has got a lower point of
control you're probably safe and staying
short and again just back to our chart
right
if you're short and you're seeing lower
points of controls if you're seeing
negative deltas if you're seeing selling
imbalances
you're pretty safe and staying short
if you're getting long and all of a
sudden you see positive deltas
stringing together you're seeing higher
points of controls you're seeing buying
imbalances
it's it's safe to stay long so you know
if you're short
coming down in here and you see this is
what i'm talking about right where i say
you know
order flow lets you see what's happening
in the bar market's selling off here
then all of a sudden you see these very
weak delta numbers right just
7 negative 7 negative 23 minus 7
0 right and 68
well for this market to keep going down
you're going to want to see a nice
strong
negative delta you want to see strong
aggressive selling but it's not there
it's very weak it's seven it's 23 it's
seven it's zero
and instead see it turned positive and
quite strong positive 115 127 you're
seeing the buying imbalances coming in
so if you're short from here when you
run it start running into this stretch
in here where the deltas just get really
weak
in terms of close to zero
that you know the the when i say weak i
mean the aggressive selling is is
lightening up
then you know start looking for signs of
aggressive buying coming in
and for the market to go back up and
then you see it right away
see the delta is very strong positive
you're seeing
aggressive buying coming in here and
you're seeing points in control
go higher okay that's what i'm talking
about keep you on
the right side of the market but more
importantly tell you when the market
is turning now why does that matter is
because you know
every trading book right every trading
guru
says let your winners run and cut your
losing trades early
but if you're just following price
everything looks the same
you know on the chart because you can't
see the intensity of the buying or
selling that's incurred
in the market right now right and that's
what overflow does it gets you
as close to the market as possible
what's happening right now
right you're not using a moving average
or any sort of average
you know based on the last 20 bars less
30 bars less 50 bars you're trading
based on
what's trading right now it's the
freshest information that's available
to a trader so the misconception a lot
of traders have
is thinking that cutting your losses
short is about having tight stops
it's not right having tight stops caused
you to take a lot of unnecessary losses
due to market movements right the way
you cut your losses short
is by knowing marking conditions have
changed and getting out
right so again
if you're short here now you're starting
to see strong positive deltas come in
what do you think you know you're going
to wait till it comes back up here and
stops you out
or break even no you can get out right
now
right if you're starting to see rising
points of controls
if you're short and also you start
seeing points controls
zipping higher what do you think is
happening well volume is migrating
higher
that's not a good sign if you're short
right or if you're short and you start
seeing buying imbalances appearing in
the bars
well that's another sign of aggressive
buyers are appearing but when you see
all three
it doesn't get any more obvious and this
was just this morning at seven
in the crude oil right you got that nice
little sell off the nice little rally
there
so as a trader right you don't want to
be fighting the tape right because
that's a fight you're going to lose
consistently and you know a lot of
people
like to fight the market and there's no
point in doing it because you're going
to lose
all right you might win one or two
times but overall the market's going to
knock you out
essentially all right so
find winning trades in the order flow
right this is
um you know what everyone wants to know
how can i use order flow to find those
trades
well there's there's a lot of different
setups you know personally i've got
about
50 setups but when i say setups you know
it's more of of nuances i don't see them
all
all day long you know i mean some of
them you know i
don't say rare but you know when they
happen i know when to take them but i'm
going to talk about two simple ones
right they're very underutilized and
not many people use them and the beauty
of these setups is
they're easy to see when you look at the
order flow what if you're looking at a
normal chart you can't see them
okay because you need to be looking at
imbalances or delta
now these are not overly complex they're
very simple
that anybody can can use them tomorrow
as long as you have access to a
footprint chart and this is how you grow
as a trader right
you take what you know you learn from a
presentation you know
on you know that i'm doing today or one
of the other speakers is doing later
and you see how you could use that in
your trading right and
you know successful traders don't go out
and they just don't go out and
buy you know by successful traders i
mean you know people that um
make a living trading and you know they
don't go out and just buy some
trading system off the shelf and use it
like that no they
they learn a method of trading and they
develop it to suit their style
right and that's why i like doing these
presentations because you know i do get
the emails
once in a while saying hey you know i
watched your presentation and
you know i took what you're teaching
there and modified it to my
training style and my strategy and you
know i'm doing really well
you know so that that's why i really
love doing these presentations
so the first one is multiple imbalances
in a bar
now remember an imbalance occurs when
there are more aggressive buyers than
sellers in the 2a auction by a
predetermined percentage right four to
one 400 percent meaning you have four
times as many aggressive buyers
than aggressive sellers or vice versa
now
at any price level there may be a buying
or selling a balance but
what do you think it means when there
are three or four
or more imbalances in a bar right well
the order flow
is exhibiting strong directional trade
and what do i mean by that is
well if you look at you know this market
is mostly going sideways right
it's nothing happening this is um
yesterday in the e-minis right we're
just sort of going
drifting sideways you know obviously we
got some news coming out later
but then boom you see one two three
selling it balances
well that's important okay it's
important information and you're not
getting that off a normal bar chart
you're just seeing well it's a red bar
right but what happens is you know it's
a quick drop from you know
uh 44 44 a half 45 you know straight
down to 42
41 and a half you know it's a quick
three-point scalp not three ticks three
points right
i know a lot of traders like to talk
about their scalp trades oh i made uh
three two
three ticks i got two ticks um you know
you want points
right that's where monies are made is in
points
not ticks but this market looked like it
was going nowhere
dead in the water then the aggressive
sellers appeared you know so
well you could take that trade you know
just a quick trade you know last
five ten minutes three points
um again this is yesterday also you may
just a little bit
prior to that again we're just sort of
hanging around here right going sideways
up down up down
but on this up bar you see three
buying imbalances okay that's your sign
right the order flow is speaking to you
so to speak
um that hey you know what aggressive
buyers are present even in the next bar
right you also got three buying
imbalances
and what happens you know i mean again
it's another uh
three four point move you know in the
next five
seven minutes okay and you know as as a
trader
imagine if you could get you know three
or four
three-point moves a day in the e-minis
you know how that can
transform your trading results right and
you know even earlier in the day this is
when we were at
just after the cash open we're sort of
trading up near that high
well the first time you got some three
you got what four or five selling
balances in this bar
okay didn't work out right but if you're
watching the order flow
okay rather than getting stopped out up
here you're seeing rising point of
control rising point of control
coming in here you're seeing the
positive delta you're seeing buying
imbalances
right when you saw the aggressive
selling but instead now you're seeing
aggressive buying
that could be your sign to get out you
hit the new high
by a tick and then boom the aggressive
selling comes back in
strong negative deltas starts selling
off goes sideways before it falls over
okay so you know there was some trades
some points to be had here
this one you know even if you took the
full stop out here
you could have made it back in the next
trade right but ideally you're watching
the order flow
and you could recognize well you know
what i'm short but i'm seeing
a positive delta positive delta positive
delta
points and controls are all sudden going
in the other direction that's not a good
sign instead
i'm seeing buying imbalances that's why
i talk about by how you could use the
order flow
to help your trading by by seeing things
that
other traders aren't seeing in the
market
okay now the thing with multiple
imbalances is
they could appear practically anywhere
okay but
you should always trade in context of
the market
right you want to be looking for reasons
to get short
at highs of the day or swing highs or in
sideways markets you know if you're
about to break out of a sideways
activity
and the same would be for if you're
looking to get long
right you can be looking to get long at
swing lows or lows of the day
or if you're breaking out of sideways
activity just like here we're at the
highs of the day
okay i'm not trying to pick this to be
the high of the day
i'm letting the market tell me you know
what we're at the high of the day
aggressive sellers are coming in
and i know as a trader if you're at
highs and also you start seeing
aggressive traders
the market has a strong tendency to sell
off
now in this case the first one you know
the market
uh came back up and made a new high by a
tick before it
fell over okay you know that happens
that's trading
you know here is a market going sideways
just about to break out
to the upside the sign multiple
imbalances
right it was a market that was going
sideways
all right about to break down what was
the sign
multiple selling imbalances so you can
see
how just you know a simple simple thing
of imbalances can help your trading
right it's going to help you understand
that
hey you know what we're starting to
break down this is the thing that's
giving the market the push
or you know that we're starting to
we're getting ready to start move up
right but you you want to look for that
trigger right and the trigger in this
case is
the multiple buying imbalances right and
then you see the market popped up
so again multiple balances can appear
practically anywhere but you take them
in context of the market selling
imbalances at or near highs or sideways
markets if we're about to
break down or if you're looking to get
long you know look for buying multiple
bars with multiple buying and balances
near the low
or swing lows or a market that's about
to break up
break out to the upside okay so the
second one
i'll talk about today is the delta surge
now remember delta is the net difference
between aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers in a bar and
generally as the market goes up there's
positive delta
and as the market goes down there's
negative delta
now where it gets interesting is when
you start analyzing delta over
several bars okay now again you know
delta could be positive or negative or
even zero in a bar you know when it
lands on zero
in a bar i've found it's just more
coincidence than than anything else
there's no no special meaning
but i don't know you know maybe somebody
will find
a hundred thousand bars with zero delta
and then tell me something different but
i found it's just it's coincidence
because it could be the difference of
one trade right
um you know it could be a difference of
one lot it'd be going positive or
negative
but generally as the market goes up you
have positive delta
and as the market goes down you have
negative delta now a surge
occurs when delta grows over several
bars
so in other words more and more and even
more aggressive buyers come into the
market you're seeing buyers pile
into the market okay opposite would be
true for a market that's selling off
you're going to see more against the
aggressive selling than more aggressive
selling and even more aggressive selling
coming into the markets like everybody's
running
for the exit i gotta get out you know so
you see buying just getting stronger and
stronger and stronger
as the market starts selling off most of
the time
trading is mixed but the sequential
increase in aggressive buying
or aggressive selling is very telling to
traders okay
now here's here's a few examples all
right so
what do we have here well we've got
um this is e-mini's from yesterday i'm
sorry from this morning this morning at
eight o'clock you know a lot of people
think that oh
you know what you can't trade the the
night session well you can right with
order flow you can look at it you know
people say i
get scared because it's such light
volume but actually you know the volume
in the e-minis
is is very good right for for a trader
you can you can trade those markets um
using order flow quite nicely but this
is a market that's going sideways this
morning right then it drops it drops
from
um you know oh five or oh four
down to you know you know down to 90 you
know down to double o down to 98
i mean you get this big push down but
what was the sign right just looks like
you're just going sideways
right points controls all sort of lined
up nothing special
in the imbalances but if you're looking
at the delta right this was
sort of the clue right it went from
positive then it's negative 12
negative 33 negative 48. so it's telling
you there's
just a little bit more selling going on
in each bar and
i know that as a as a trader when i work
for the big trading firms
you know when you have a big order you
got to piece it in
right you just don't go in and whack the
market 10 points you sell
some see if the market takes it okay
they take it sell some more
okay take that sell some more all right
so
that's where the delta surge alerts you
to
what's happening in the market okay and
again that was
four in the morning this morning okay
this is after midnight
right after midnight last night
um 12 15 chicago time right you just see
it's just again it's mark it looks so
dead
you know it's just that's midnight you
know who trades midnight well a lot of
people trade midnight you know a lot of
the big
trading um firms and funds they have
night desks right people
not just one person sitting there
watching
cable all night you know you got a staff
of three four traders there
um following these markets trading them
so you see here it went you know it's
just mostly going nowhere then all of a
sudden
the buying increases 12 51 69
you also got multiple buying and
balances in here one two three
so you got two things going on you got
delta search delta increasing
i'm not going to talk about the points
of control here um
but that's you know also bullish but the
surge 12 51
69 so the other testing the water
testing the water got a little bit
aggressive here
caused a stack buying a balance buy some
more
okay boom they're done okay and what
happens
market just moves nicely and you know
this is
at midnight all right you're talking to
me from 41
almost up to 43. you know it's not the
biggest move but it's midnight so you
can see these moves
have some meaning to them even in the
middle of the night
here's another example this was around 8
o'clock last night
in the e-minis all right looks like the
market's just going sideways
right boom just drifting sideways
between you know 46
and 47 and a half but then the selling
starts picking up
minus 16 minus 16 minus 35 minus 67 even
minus 72 minus 86 it just keeps growing
here as the market's selling off
but right here was the sign minus 16
minus 35 minus
you know you're getting short in here
around the 46 46 and a quarter level
and it just trades straight down
straight down to 43. obviously somebody
is testing the waters okay i could sell
some i could sell so i'm not really
moving the market
okay i'm not really moving the market
excel some more okay then other traders
start picking up what's happening
that the market is starting to tick down
they start joining them
and the market starts winding its way
down okay
so that's what you're going to look for
you know in the order flow
obviously points and controls are also
moving lower
so you could put these things together
right i've talked about point of control
talked about imbalances and i've talked
about delta
right and you can see how simple it is
just by looking at the chart
now if this is the first time you're
looking at a footprint chart
okay you know spend some time with it
get to understand what these different
things mean what point of control means
what delta means what imbalances mean
and
you know you're going to be much better
off as a trader in my opinion
now a delta surge can appear anywhere
right
but ideally you're going to look for
them in sideways markets especially
and the reason for that is because
nobody's expecting any
sudden movement and if you're starting
to see signs of aggressive buying
or aggressive selling and is getting
stronger
in that direction that's your cue as a
trader to go with it
right just you know it's like writing
it's like surfing you know get on the
wave and
write it for as long as you can so
hopefully by now you can see how
powerful
order flow analysis is right you don't
need to over complicate
your trading right i think as humans we
like to over complicate things
but if you just trade what's happening
right in front of you you're going to be
much better off than
than trying to come up with all these
strange calculations i just showed you
two simple setups right it doesn't
involve any calculations just involves
looking at at the screen right
so if you found this helpful and you
really like my overflows
trader software i what what i use in in
the
uh presentation i've got a special
package for you
to make your trading a lot easier and
what it includes is
it's the order flows trader 3.0 for
ninjatrader 8.
it doesn't run on sierra charts or
tradestation it's programmed for
ninjatrader 8
because you know the programmer that i
had for it is a program for ninjatrader
8 and
that's the software that i've been using
for trading futures for a long time
and it's a volume footprint chart with
17 pre-programmed order flow indicators
i didn't really talk about any of those
indicators in
here you know but we have an indicator
in there to help you
see what's happening in the delta um you
know find out
when it's weakening find out points of
controls that act as support and
resistance
um you know find you know now we've
added tools
for value looking at the value areas of
bars and things like that
so it's a very very robust
footprint chart as opposed to a normal
footprint chart
okay and i say you get my chart template
but honestly you don't need my chart
template because
the when you install the software into
ninjatrader eight
it's already programmed for a e-mini
one-minute chart and you can just adjust
it from there
and normally i sell it for 8.99 but
you're not going to pay that today
but i realize that having order flow
software is one thing the next thing is
knowing how to use it
so i just give you the software and send
you on your way say bye bye i provide a
lot of further education on how to trade
with order flow and each week
i do a live group training session for
my users if you can't attend you can
watch the recording
and there's there's already well over
you know 125
presentations in there i don't expect
you to watch them all but
you know you can attend them live
and ask your questions about order flow
or the software
but i'm there you know to answer your
questions and
you know there are other people out
there that want to charge you like 200 a
month for that
you get it for free you know it's like
you get my software you know i want to
provide
um a space for you to go each week that
you know you got questions you can come
find me
now i also give you
access to my order flows trading course
and normally i sell this for 297.
you're going to get access to it's a 20
uh lesson course
about 15 hours long but it's it's a
great course
for learning the basics of order flow
and
to take it to the next level i give you
access to my order flows
inner circle video series and
honestly the only way you get this now
is through this special offer
i don't offer it outright anymore
but when i did it was for 497 and what's
inside is there's 56 videos on
advanced order flow uh tricks tips
and forms of analysis
so if you start adding all that together
right the software
899 the training 297 the inner circle
video series
497 the weekly group training yeah
you're already looking at
close to seventeen hundred dollars but
don't worry you know it's
the barrier to entry is much lower than
that and
as a special for you know because
investors x will keep inviting me back
i got an extra bonus the order flow
playbook right there's it's an
it's a little video course i did on
order flow
there's 10 or 11 order flow trade setups
in there and this course normally sells
for 297 but you can get it for free
today
uh when you pick up the package and you
add all that up together it comes out to
almost two thousand dollars
right which is a lot of money right but
again i'm not going to ask that much for
you you know
i believe in keeping the barrier to
entry low
but you know this is what other people
have been saying about the software
right they've been saying uh
mike your flows trader software is
remarkably helpful because i can clearly
see now what's happening in the market
like for example who's in control on a
very specific time and who's getting
weaker as well
right and there's a lot of positive
feedback out there
now you gotta remember right if you want
to be successful in anything well you
have to start you know there's steps
right you got to learn you got to train
yourself you need instruction you need
practice and
that's why i created this package for
you so that you can get all that
so if you're interested just go to
www.com order flows
off three dot html and it's just a
one-time payment of 749
right that's much less than the if you
were to buy all that stuff separately of
almost
two thousand dollars now there's going
to be no more monthly payments you know
i can't stand you know these vendors out
there say oh we're gonna charge you 199
a month and then you go to cancel it and
you can't cancel it you even gotta
cancel your credit card and then you're
still getting charged for it right
it's crazy like that i don't believe in
that it's just a one-time payment you
get access to
you know upgrades in the future and all
that
now you will obviously have to pay for
data fees
you know your your data stream from um
a data source or from your broker and
you got to pay whatever ninja trader
fees if you're trading through
ninjatrader
but my software will work on the free
version if you want to use ninjatrader
as just a charting platform so if you go
to www.com off three i put it in the
chat already
that html it takes you to this page just
scroll down
you know scroll down the side takes you
to this button
just click that button right there takes
it to paypal paypal
processes your payment i don't get your
credit card information i don't want it
and then you know within a short period
i will
send you all your login information your
download details you know it takes a
little while for paypal to process the
information and get
everything sent to me so um if you're
interested
just go to www.orderflows.com3.html
so if you're interested in my book you
can get it by going to this
url here www.orderflows.com
html you'll need to enter your name and
email address and click submit
okay that will take you to the download
page where you can download it you're
not gonna get the hard copy you'll just
get a
download so act now
go to orderflows.com it's all in the
chat
already and thank you anna for having me
here
and i'll throw it back to you
thank you so much michael great
presentation thank you
let's move to our next presenter jody
samuels
hello judy
hello hello